[Music]
just do me a favor just for the bit can
you not just no no no damn it I just I
didn't look though okay
I want to set this up and then I'm going
to tell you to look okay all right okay
you ready
remember we had with Theory yesterday's
episode on locals that
George Stephanopoulos
wants to get rid of Michael Strahan and
he's sending him all these places oh of
course it's a theory well
turned down to what was another step
another chapter in space history in this
country and along for this ride one
you want to read it Michael's Trey hands
journey to space
they're really trying to kill this man
George is trying to kill this guy what
do you mean he survived the polar bears
all right send him to [ __ ] space set
him the [ __ ]
and not on one of those good Elon Musk
musk Richard Branson Rockets I want him
to go up on a [ __ ] rickety NASA
rocket I don't want him to go in a like
the space equivalent of a public bus
stray hand yes blue origin that rocket
blasted off going to the edge of space
with six crew members on board and among
them one year is this an old one it's
only a month old
so he's got a space in there now he's
visible for the polar bears
Homer
this is why Frank Grimes hated Homer
because he's an idiot he's an idiot
everything you went to space remember
Frank Grimes you went to space
oh my God that's what it is and
Stephanopoulos died or has friends
called him Steffy
I wanna how is he how do you top space I
am a colleague Michael Strahan and the
robot here with us now we watch this
together I had a different scene they I
didn't know this so Michael Strahan went
on one of the blue origin Rockets yeah
so anybody you could go to space so he's
so he's black Forrest Gump
right there in the desert to watch this
thing take off on Saturday it was it was
in an incredible moment for me even more
momentum was for Michael Strahan and yes
it brought a whole new meaning to the
word touchdown I went there for our
friend straight we asked him about it I
know you went there but like did you
need to
this trip he said it's almost like an
out of Body Experience
[Music]
members bless testing off into space
Saturday morning on the new Shepherd
capsule beyond the 62. like a dick right
yeah it's the penis one that's the penis
one look man you like Elon and you can
now but you gotta admit elon's Rockets
are way cooler looking right yes this is
[ __ ] his Rockets are so gay elon's the
one that's sitting and going I'm sorry
but I believe that they look like a
phallus yeah we're gonna have to
redesign it yeah we're gonna be here and
you're like God damn it man [ __ ]
we're gonna be here all year because
this [ __ ] guy is such a perfectionist
we need to make them look less like
penises hi Carmen line also elon's going
to let everyone go to space for just
eight bucks a month so that's pretty
cool yeah
and they'll still complain you're right
uh space travels a human right oh good
that too everything else why not marking
the edge of space
this is so much fun back on Earth I
spent the morning reporting live from
Blue origin watch site one with my
fellow ABC colleagues there is nothing I
imagined quite like experiencing a
rocket blast off here on Earth except
for you know like them telling the
spiking my Jeffrey Epstein story and
then me shutting up about it for years
because I didn't want to lose my career
because they gave me a cushy Good
Morning America job that pays well and I
don't have to work hard at all meanwhile
I could have just quit and been a brave
person and I would have been a hero to
Millions but here we are with Michael
Strahan sending them to space sending a
[ __ ] football player to space
thrilled Yet full of nerves watching it
all unfold and robot this is yes we are
covering an event but this is a friend
of ours for Michael it was like game day
feel upbeat and ready to embark on an
out of this world journey I actually
feel confident and I actually I actually
feel confident I actually feel confident
going in space
I hope they let him do the controls too
you want to push one of the buttons Mike
confident and calm now I
aliens up there am I gonna go be alien
I've been a mess with no defense
with me now
with no aliens
um
prepare to do it I'm gonna be I got my
snacks I packed a bunch of snacks for
the road my wife made me a nice lunch
you put it in a bag you want to laugh
because this is a [ __ ] Apple floating
around hitting people later and saying
it's all my lunch if I told you we're
basically the Michael Strahan
um
um algorithm it's true if you Google if
you if you YouTube search Michael
Strahan polar bear our videos like the
third one at the top
father Gonna Be Epic if I'm Gonna Be
Epic I think everyone else outside it
sounds like Eddie Murphy's buckwheat
impression okay
foreign
I am they're on their way the crew made
their way to the launch pad with him he
was one of the best football players his
position ever that's what's crazy it's
like how did you turn into whatever this
is
cheering from friends family and Mission
Control then up the stairs to the launch
tower all the training and practice
coming down to these moments astronaut
stray how do you read me okay but is
that really your haircut
well I cannot read you but I can hear
you but unfortunately I cannot read on a
radio
is that what you meant Oh you may hear
you yes I can hear you fine well I'm
sorry I can read you just fine he smiles
the big teeth yeah I think [ __ ] gap
teeth
by the way can I say I want to be I
don't hate Michael Strahan no I love
myself
because what he's doing is so funny
lately I I cannot believe what's
happening
ladies and gentlemen it is time to
launch Strahan is my new favorite anime
protagonist he is he keeps going on all
these Adventures
oh [ __ ] okay so we're leaving now but
have a good morning America to go fight
the aliens
Marco there's there's no aliens we're
just breaking the atmosphere for two
minutes we're just it's really a quick
loopback we're going we're going high
enough that you can float around and
we're coming right there it's quick it's
real quick
man engine start are we gonna get to see
moth no oh my God how long will it take
the seam off
I don't know how long it takes to see
Mars
two one
how it's really happening the capsule
making its way back oh there it is right
there getting pinned with his astronaut
Wings the final civilians to receive
this honor from the FAA
I am so proud of you oh my God you have
no idea so tell me how do you feel right
now do you feel different well I could
tell you this Lawrence Taylor never went
to space [ __ ] him
so it looks like I got you beat in that
metric
[Music]
oh you at WrestleMania I went to space
oh this whole thing his whole life is
just trying to get back
see you wrestle Bam Bam Bigelow I went
to Faith I got to see the moon
so it's it's surreal like out of out of
it's It's such it's almost like an
out-of-body experience you know it's
hard to believe I'll check it out I
believe it happened and it's such a the
feeling of almost being
good
day
hey hey tape hey taper later when I tell
you to click this oh and you ask that
has to be the thumbnail there's the
thumbnail
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ]
you know what this is too because he
sacked your Bledsoe once and it was the
beginning of the end of Drew bledsoe's
career
so
oh [ __ ] man oh my God
yeah
faith faith being completely out of
control you'd completely trust
your life is in the hands of other
people see the reason why everybody is
so nice to me is because I took out
Vengeance lunch you bledso on behalf of
Tom Brady
and America's paying me back
Tom Brady made the phone call to
president Trump and got me the faith
he said look man this guy really just
made a [ __ ] out of your blood so please
okay help me out here I owe him one who
are you deemed smarter than you know
exactly what's going to happen at
certain points and how to take you up
and bring you down safely and they
couldn't have been better here I mean it
was fantastic but it's a crazy feeling
like the feeling of weight listen at the
feeling when the booster goes off the
rocket goes off and it honestly I peed
in my suit when they told me it's not
one of the one of those spaces you could
be in is that like though not one of the
like the most baller fringe benefits of
doing this what is that you get the
spacesuit with your name on it oh yeah
dude that's the coolest part of the
whole thing right I wouldn't even need
to go to space I'd be like can I just
get one of those outfit that's pretty
cool and then best was like no it's only
people that went to space and then I'll
buy a fake one in AliExpress No One's
Gonna Know there you go you think you
think he and I have ever been to
Roberta's Steakhouse no we haven't but
we have a jacket of course not patches
and you don't know what's up from down
and your body just goes well I hope you
would because if you don't know what's
up and down you're gonna crash the
rocket right into the ground
seat belt but naturally it feels natural
well I feel so weird and lightheaded we
haven't left Earth yet
to move you're like but if you swim you
don't go anywhere you actually have to
push off things they're testing very
gently but it feels very natural and
just see the curvature the atmosphere oh
no actually oh Flat Earth flat Earth
don't it's a dome this is fake Flat
Earth oh so yeah Michael Strahan's now
pushing this [ __ ] Globe custom big
Globe I didn't know I didn't know
Strahan was a globe [ __ ] I guess he is
[ __ ]
the glow wow
this is just [ __ ] the Deep State bro
but why wouldn't the Deep State get
somebody we you know people respect I
feel like that would be better like it's
Michael Strahan people will watch him
but people are not like oh you think
anyone's ever said hmm I wonder what
Michael Strahan has to say about this
situation
the Earth
[Music]
just it was too short
the trip was too short you have a New
Perspective it's transformational in a
way that is transformation in a lot of
ways happens before you even go
because I'm out of your family a lot of
your friends a lot of people who you
know for me being a football player all
the tough talk with your boys when
you're getting ready to do something
like first off if you ever in a locker
room went tough talk with the boys
they'd beat your ass well that's not
what they talking like in the longer
would be Michael Strahan's ass no
you know they'd beat the kicker's ass if
he talked like that I love you in fact
straight hand goes talking with the boys
and then they beat up the kicker because
they can't beat up Michael Strahan come
here
and and all the things that come out
that you would I was trying to think of
a kicker and it completely blanked not
expect to hear
um Tony Tupa Adams they beat up Tony
Tupac Jesus that's [ __ ] quite a
[ __ ] reference Pete stoyanovich
[Applause]
which in a lot of ways transformational
and and my understanding of how much I
love people here how much I people love
me here you went to space for like three
minutes bro I missed I missed you guys
so much
and my relationship in their life and
their relationship in my life and the
importance of it the astronauts right
trust me Stephanopoulos will send you
again with his money and I'm gonna walk
and talk moonwalk so here's the thing
and here's something that you that you
might uh wait what is this it's a little
more tomorrow I cannot wait Robin George
TJ I cannot wait to tell you all about
my trip to space and also everyone there
at home and
[Music]
so by the way here's something that you
probably forgot they've been trying to
push straight hand for a while
and because remember he was our Regis
and Kelly when he took over for whenever
we know when whatever's fine but before
that
did you know in 2009 he had one season
of a show no
the show was called Brothers it's 2009.
it's about Michael Strahan it's about
Sean and Marlon Wayans and then they'd
like their dad has like a diamond
Brothers oh okay now oh they're the uh
the tag team from Impact doc Gallows
Carl Anderson no they're the they're the
Mexican tag team the Lucha Brothers okay
um
so anyway Royce couldn't think of the
good Brothers well the well Brothers The
Well Brothers
The Wellness violation Brothers
um anyway
he had a 2009 this is the trailer of the
show do you remember this show no it was
one of those UPN shows
um and it was him it's if he's playing a
fictionalized version of himself
a lot of teeth jokes mostly teeth jokes
and his brother's in a wheelchair
okay you know we're about to have both
of them in this house at the same time
[Music]
hello son hey Pop oh yeah you look great
man in fact I'm in the best way to the
list not only before I'm playing the
trailer and then I have a proposal for
Merch after the trailer so let me finish
the trailer come on hit me you afraid to
hurt your little hand
soccer
would you watch him pop oh championship
game against the Packers man you really
stumped the place up worst part is you
got outrun by a white quarterback
so let me let me get this straight so
he's a retired NFL guy yes but his dad
just like watches his old games to talk
[ __ ] about him yeah who does who watches
old sports games
well I mean if your dad's Apollo Creed
hey man this place is like a shrine to
me you should have named it Mike's world
it's called trainers cause that's my
name why is my face on the sign of neon
that's me and what they're Gap in the
front teeth
lightning
[Music]
you know what you should do with your
two front teeth
introduce them
what is this music it's like man I'll
take your boat out to the wood [ __ ] hey
Pop we don't own a wood shed well I
wasn't a frog man either I can still
kick your butts like I told you man I
don't need you around everybody's not
impressed with you right Roscoe yeah
that's right
get the hell out of here Roscoe all
right boss you delusional man look
around I packed this place do I told you
this is my wreck the crowd man will
nobody need you up in here man you
invited to leave whenever you get ready
chill is that the way you want it that's
the way I want it what is the point of
this what is the drama part of the show
because it's not even the comedy it's
drama part of the show it's not even
drama
what the hell are you talking about I
didn't have my stroke he didn't have a
stroke but he is not fine he's losing it
I am not losing it yes you are I think
you are yeah trust me you are popular
[Music]
the music changes like three times
there's no like
this show has no Identity or Rhythm to
it this show has CTE too yes
Brothers
coming soon to Fox sorry fox fox yeah
there was a dark time in 2009 for Fox so
here's what I'm thinking
once you finish the undateables which
we're doing on locals which is great I'm
thinking that we line up another show
about retards I'm thinking that I have
all 13 episodes of this okay but you
know
we should call it Brothers fair enough
fair enough I'm down to watch it I think
that'll be fine it'll be great that'll
be replacing undateables this is what I
was thinking um